The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
MICHEL DEGRAFF: I don't want
to make anyone jealous who
came before, but I think
we can say pretty safely
that we saved one of the
best for last, right?
I won't say the best.
OK?
All right.
So as you can see,
throughout the course
we looked at these issues about
how language, race, ethnicity,
gender, how they can be used
to create various hierarchies.
And as you can see now
after the semester,
these are tools, really.
They're not inherently
part of who we are,
but they are tools that
various pools of power
use to keep control,
to create hierarchies.
And I think last week, you guys
you had a very good discussion
with Dr. Aleman about how
sometimes these hierarchies can
be internalized.
And there was a very
good discussion,
as I can tell, from the video
that she took for me about how
you, yourself, we need to
do some work inside of us
to go beyond these threats that
these terror attacks impose
on us.
So we went very micro.
So we went very macro,
then went micro.
And today, with my friend
and colleague, Noam Chomsky,
we're going to go
my macro again.
But I guess you've
read the papers.
I read the papers.
And I must say, Noam, I was
very disturbed by what I read.
But the fact is that
those are the data.
So this is MIT.
We are very much involved in
trying to understand knowledge.
And many of you
throughout the semester
made a case that we have all
this knowledge here at MIT.
But often, this knowledge
does not translate into action
into the real world.
And in a way, I think
with Noam's entire life,
we have an example of
how that can happen.
How we can take very
abstract, technical knowledge
and make it available
to the world
and try to make it better.
And the theme of this
course throughout
was how to build bridges, how to
make change and build bridges.
So we hope that with
Noam today, we'll
get a clear sense of
how that can happen.
And perhaps, how we
might, with some luck,
save the world, right?
NOAM CHOMSKY: I
think the best way
to proceed is-- in a court
seminar is for you to say
what you're interested in.
I'll see if I have some
way of reacting to it.
Lots of things I
could talk about.
I mean, one thing we
could talk about related
is right in the headlines.
So there are things which is an
opening for things we can do.
That's the plan that was
just made public yesterday
to deport Haitians back
to Haiti from Boston.
That's a very live issue.
A lot of lives depend on it.
We can do something about
it right here if we want.
It turns out-- I
didn't know this--
that the Haitian
Ambassador, Michel just
told me, who is pleading
with the government
not to carry out this
onerous and destructive act,
is actually a former
MIT student, who
wrote about these
topics in his thesis.
So that's one of many things
that could be discussed.